ciao a tutti youtube negli ultimi anni
non è diventato più semplicemente una
passione unita anche a un lavoro ma è
diventato anche un modo per portarmi e
spingermi a fare delle esperienze o
delle attività che di base non fare mai
una tra queste è ridipingere il mio
salone ho sempre pensato lo farò prima o
poi lo farò prima o poi ma soprattutto
lo farò fa temo che questa qui possa
annoverarsi fra le esperienze che di
base non avrei mai potuto provare la mia
vita quelle cose per cui i tuoi inizi
bene
finisce male tipo i matrimoni e niente
mi sono deciso ed è arrivato il momento
di farlo fallo fallo basta è stato
convincendo di farlo farlo farlo farlo
letto sono appena uscito dal negozio
preso tutto quello che mi serve
ho il terrore di aver fatto una cazzata
ma una cazzata aiutatemi a dire cazzate
a chiamarmi scemo concedere al nostro
andando a dipingere le mura rosa tutto
in rosa non voglio pure mettermi a far
gli affreschi il tasso di è possibile
che questa cosa diventi non è altissimo
signori vi presento i rinforzi ma che
cos'ha portato non correte al 32 la
notte gabriele ma perché è preso tuo
fratello e questo per i cappellini e
cappellini e reso alti si è tramutata in
beta che prepara bellissime posso venire
certo io avevo già messo solo annalisa
però se questa è l'america questa che
merita gabriele sapevo che ti avrei
colpito su per le scarpe e che cosa ha
pensato in uno scarso che tinteggia c'è
questa te lo ricordi così fanno i
cattivi si facciamo un tutorial angelo
arrivo di altri rinforzi alloggiano
igenti pittore anteriore che aveva visto
pittore artista
puoi scegliere tra look di gabriele o la
tuta quella di un aiuto
la breakdance anti coronavirus dipendere
il giornale è impiegato questo mi sa che
vieri enorme messaggi leva si commette
sopra tutte le brevi lettere certo se lo
ricordi veramente non ci credo però che
ci vuole un genio
no ma che peter pan c'è la piega girano
ripiega e per me tu non ci siamo non
possiamo dipingere per pellicole di
chiuso di vincere come fa un cappellino
di carta da muratore a meno calorico
zavoli girato raggirato l'ha girato la
girato la girato cerca la cosa che non
mi quadra si sa che cosa hai fatto
eccolo questo qui è il cappellino che
suggerisce di lui
no no non è questo poi un qualcosa che
non sia perfettissimo vorrei qualcosa
nello rega e allora chiamato le persone
giuste
e sempre un preservativo usato considera
la cosa che nel mio look il piede e
rigorosamente nudo e poi il cappellino
io sì che non sempre questa punta che
questa va premuta prima di infilarlo
cioè che genere fatti io ragazzi
decisero di centro di lucca lo metto
pure io allora cosa ma quindi la mia e
della misura vostra c'è solo questa
ricchezza olio pentro lentamente il
regolamento e scrivi in un tab sotto e
non vorrei neanche sporcare le mutande
solo perché c'è la macchina da presa
cioè tu staresti nudo con questo così e
così a parte che nei 600 volte a metà
stretto questo tono ragazzi e 6 anti
guerra c'era un pantalone in stile
salopette di raggio non posso però la
cerniera non osteggiare però perché di
servire anche i prossimi per nei
prossimi giorni vi spiego che cosa
voglio fare io non lo so io non sapevo
dei prossimi giorni quindi ci ha
chiamato con l'inganno qui ragazzi
venite un attimo in quell hd matura tre
giorni nel corso della vita della terra
tre giorni non sono niente spiegaci un
attimo e quello già alla situazione
critica che entrava canotta sopra tanto
stile vero che si è personalizzata del
diverso l'idea è quella di togliere il
quadro adios amigos bella ciao
anzi questo quadro dove andrà a finire
credo che lo porteremo nell'ufficio
appena avremo ufficio a queste due
pareti neri dipingiamo completamente
rosa antico una penale oggi quindi
dobbiamo sigillare tutto e creare questo
dovere che fate rosantico in modo che
domani potremo affrescare con un disegno
che immagino qui all'angolo e fare un
enorme carta tipo giapponese garantito
conflitto da dove proviene questo
malcontento cosa che rimane la novità
sono come le ragazze con i capelli e
rinfresco casa partiamo con l'isolamento
delle parti nevralgiche della parete
meno male che ci ha pensato gianluigi
sullo scotch non è che l'ho preso per
herat a firenze perché il termosifone st
20 centimetri di altezza dal pavimento
perché così puoi sfruttare anche il
calore viene da sotto cioè non ci passa
scovano sala motto di aiuti a spostare
se con la telecamera fly
[Musica]
adesso mi fermo una forza di falde rivi
natale al contrario cosa piccola come
ridotto per te il piede quello che non
fanno molto bene ragazzi
stendiamo un velo pietoso
[Musica]
i miei ragazzi finalmente hanno fatto
girare le loro rotelle potrebbe essere
una grande idea come mag roncato
sì ci dobbiamo mettere lo stucco in
pasta scacco in pasta signori milady
ogni io vado a punto del non ritorno
ma il nostro colore è bello intenso e
possiamo di vincere noi
sono venuto qui per dipingere non ha
fatto niente adesso piacere bocca più
bello di tutti come dice cioè add on
human siriu bicing mi hanno trovato il
pennello di mano dicendole che non ero
in grado neanche di pitturare cosa che
non ritengo vera come se fossi veramente
l'ultimo pittore della terra che ci
vuole a mo di vigo sottrai venelli che
mi avete chiamato per guardare sono capi
segno dell'infinito
ma guarda che si va così guarda come
viene ben capire se su per favore
capriate nella gabriele teneva il
castigo dietro l'angolo c'è a 30 anni
voi non riuscite a divertirvi mentre
lavorate è tanto semplice un poco di
zucchero la pillola va giù la pillola
la pillola ne monti per il caso non
sapeva niente giusto da casa
allora dimmi quello che vuoi cosa cambia
tra quello quello che facevo io
guarda che stai facendo stai sbaraccando
sui muri e aggiornamento sto imparando
ottenere malware bravo piccoli grandi
passi l'unica cosa non vorrei che questo
colore tende a chiudere in pole ambiente
posso dire che mi piace troppo o in
conte su una una casa magari piccola che
ha unico ambiente e tu sei una casa che
comunque ai belli mammalucchi belli
sordi belli metriquadri cioè non è che
c'è solo il salone cioè l'altra camera
di là e la cucina parte e il suo pancino
con la camera da letto il secondo bagno
belli i sordi e learning analoghi belli
mammalucchi con la carta e 60 65 per i
quadri però c'è pure il territorio il
terrazzino
io lo chiamerei per razzoli in vendita
chi volesse comprare casa di quel bus
base d'asta da quanto partiamo
non lo so perché non sono un agente
immobiliare medica che sotto 201 200
mila euro
funziona tutto fermo riscaldata
macchinetta del caffè corpi di caffè
includono nell'affare un avvocato semi
maturo mi voglio rovinare coltelli lo
tagliamo subito cucina abitabile rossa
rosso che si sposa con rosa rosso rosa
rosa rosso rosso relativo senza macchia
d'amore ma denso questa sera poi
qualcosa di più
relativo anche antico con le macchie sul
padre pitturare abitudine non ho fatto
vedere tutto abbiamo delle scale a
chiocciola comodissime su cui su force
semi a chiocciola 1 la mezza curvatura
che ricordano una chiocciola poi questa
casa è ricca di cultura alessandro
baricco daniela delle foglie non so che
sia salendo troviamo un maestoso
lucernario che i vostri momenti più
intimi
immaginate che voi siete con la vostra
meta torce metà questo eletto ben
comprendendo la casa si è letto e stare
aspettando la persona amata
qui pronti in posizione la così per
questo fantastico lucernario che offre
mista impanatura uguale uguale tube male
ma le tube ha tinteggiato in realtà è
una copertura per la vendita
dell'immobile base d'asta 250 mila euro
senza contare di tutto questo
mai una singola volta ho sentito rumori
e scricchiolii presenze strane per una
casa samp l'unico che fa i rumori dentro
il palazzo e lui ormai vicini lo sanno
ecco il matto anche fatto vedere una
cosa importantissima che mettono il
pacchetto di vendita lo vedete il
pianoforte e dei primi del 1900
apparteneva alla nostra bisnonna e io
voglio mettere in vendita lo stendino
uno stendino nero che ricorda il
pianoforte che non è in vendita
o meglio come il pianoforte che può
essere anche accordato e suono
all'occorrenza come un altro procediamo
con la pittura e rendiamo nuovamente non
gli posso più video su youtube facendo e
dovrei vedere il pennello che fa così
quando
[Musica]
pitturare è uno sballo birra la spina
nel bicchiere di cristallo cioè quello
benedetto xv ma c'è niente qua c'è poco
o niente
fanno un attimo dipingere emergenza deve
riprendere perché sono mangi e bevi
soliti ubriachi e poi sono i commenti
dove non capiscono settimane un ottimo
se non avessi l'elemento di disturbo
saresti un canale bruttissimo invece
quanto è bello quello messa poco sul
capo al tuo fratello è veramente guarda
una persona senza pregevolezza ma di
vincere tutto sai fi cagando bene ma già
vinci è salvato la situazione gabriele
sta facendo tv da mangiare bene abbiamo
un piccolo aggiornamento sui fatti
adesso stiamo facendo i contorni stiamo
pitturando e stiamo attaccando lo scotch
per non va beh sapete come funziona chi
lo fa imparando persa ai una macchia sul
cui attenzione di isolante sta
vacillando se possono far vedere il web
queste cause ultimo il cane che deva la
vittima si possono far vedere le pa no
te lo pagano non ho trovato io ma anche
se spunto un testicolo che sbaglio sì ma
anche non voluto è l'amica professione
intenzionale cassano cose volgare mi è
scappato un testicolo il momento della
partita che preferisco quella fine del
gioco appiccicava ride tutto mezzo rosa
che riserve life del video che il
momento che preferisco alla fine del
gioco ma questo è il momento della
partita che preferisco
la fine del gioco speriamo che dice
meglio la fine del gioco
gianluigi porto da te è il momento della
partita che preferisco è buono però c'è
una pausa che non c'è né del cappone è
presente il pedalò biferno il momento
della partita che preferisco alla fine
del gioco ma li aveva da venire da
combinare un fascista che lavorava da
bravi la finta giorno 2
guardate la meraviglia di questa parete
di mio fratello anche era travestito da
sempre in diversi libri che ho messo in
piedi né avvertita mente sul coperchio
dell'aler di comunque erano il momento
di parlare del fatto che questa parete e
anche un po di questa avrà un disegno
non sapevo che cosa fare perché ero
molto indeciso sapevo tipo del farm
animale mano a trovarlo e quindi alla
fine ti faccio vedere che cosa ho
pensato lei una rana blu elettrico con
queste macchiette nere questo cosino cli
ge realtà è piccolo se non sbaglio tipo
così è una delle rane più velenose del
mondo e anche un messaggio le mi piace
particolarmente il fatto che una cosina
carina piccola che può sembrare
insignificante e tenera in realtà può
essere forte e da non sottovalutare
ora il problema e riuscirò a farlo non
lo so direi di iniziare a lavorare
pregate per me vi supplico punto di non
ritorno oltre si accinge
senza paura forse perché sa
perfettamente cosa c'entra la cellula
qui va avanti
comincio ad avere i primi momenti di
sconforto sera ci dovrebbe essere una
rana io ti prego fa che un semi la
parete di un asilo ti prego non
viaggiano come va sta salendo orribile
vediamo la versione che aveva fatto le
mie speranze si crede che può essere
stampati riuscendo a dalla francia e la
paura di coupè che sembri un asilo
devo dargli il tempo per rifare
sfumature migliori arredo nel senso
perché sono sempre un asino che vanno un
tocco di serie fantasy lo posso
intervenire io
pian piano molto viviamo per dal
presupposto che non sono un pittore
d'alema è detto però una cosa
difficilissima
sto andando a tappare nell'angolo riesce
a vederlo ci vuole una mezz'oretta 15
vediamo troppo ragazzi questo è il
risultato fino ad adesso sono
soddisfatto nel senso che invidio poi
viene particolarmente carina secondo me
domani ovviamente aggiungo tutte le
macchie nere dovrebbero anche un po
mandare in caciara un po di roba ma da
tempo sono pericolose perché non essere
precisissime pezzi c'è il delirio in
questo solo nei cieli prego aiuti
buongiorno mammamia gonfi di sonno e
pezzi o questo e come di riduce questo
loro qui dai sono soddisfatto
considerando che non mai tenuto in mano
un pennello non ho mai dipinto cioè un
confronto sul caravaggio
minchia caravaggio oggi faremo tutte le
parti nere cercherò anche di vedere se
riesco ad aggiustare alcune cose che
magari che questa la foto ormai
l'alleato così ricamo cantiere il capo
cantiere capo scoperto che con questo
quadro esco a fare più facilmente i
bordi di che sono tipo in un secondo
momento riempirlo poi
il risultato intanto facciamolo vedere
ragazzi sembra veramente appropriato sì
sì dai
buono questo è decisamente momento
peggiore di tutta quanta la vita se non
fosse stato per te ne sarei ammazzato
grazie
marcatori permanente però non ce la
faccio più a segnare le vecchie su
questo tizio quindi mi fermo così e
inizierò a riempirle non voglio nemmeno
sapere se mi basterà un motore almente
loro sciatella in altri sette capisco
servendo il brutto livello di difficoltà
un martello
questo qui la tua preparazione molto
medi non sai riguardo al problema che 67
deciso di fatto col pennarello
avrei perso il braccio quanta la spalla
paralizzato no per sempre bellissimo
alla vittima nel settore da cui anche
filo molto carino anche figo ma è
stupendo
ti amo bellissima signori dichiaro
ufficialmente terminata la rana sulla
parete io non ce la faccio più con quei
ripetere al coro che i suoi dettagli
abbiamo quindi il suo bianco poi sotto
l'occhio non so se vi dedica una parte
più bianca per farlo un pochino chili in
più e che in questa luce
in alcune zone di poter le gambe o cose
così ho messo la vernice lucida anche
sull'occhio in modo da dare un pochino
l'effetto bagnato però insomma non siete
tantissimi ragazzi stiamo cooperando
abbiamo quindi finito non si possono in
menu crea solo dal centro guarda guarda
che meraviglia di vita questa data come
dolorosa servizio ma rete alla fine di
questa avventura avventura hai usato in
g grazie fratello grazie capri è lì che
oggi non è potuto essere qui con noi e
ideato forse il momento di rivelare
quello che abbiamo creato tanto intonata
80 nathan tanta rada tanta tanta la
cantante ha danzato in tante reti guarda
tu mi piaci ti amo ti amo ti adoro
benvenuta 6 non torneranno più bianco e
nero che una frana
no non sto parlando il muro della mia
anima il prossimo episodio che potete
non uscite quelle file aperitivo fatelo
a casa si fa così è davvero 32 di giorni
non avrei mai detto ha detto 28 tot
massima toe o cena alla tua naturalmente